hey vsauce
michael here why though
why are any of us here what's the
purpose what does it all mean
well sometimes if we listen closely
enough when we ask
why we can hear an answer and it's
another question
why why what
our journey begins here
checking the rulebook but you won't find
anything in there it says a dog can't
play he's right
ain't no rule said the dog can't play
basketball
is that true is there really no rule
against a dog
playing middle school basketball vsauce
magic 8 ball
is there really no rule against a dog
playing basketball
the answer is yes or is it
we have begun the actor who played
airbud buddy the dog passed away
in 1998 at the age
of nine now take a look at this
let's talk about world war one
on june 28 1914
franz ferdinand the heir to the throne
of austria-hungary
and his wife sophie were assassinated in
sarajevo
while riding in a car the car's license
plate
was a iii iii118
they were killed by gavrilo princip who
said during his trial that he wanted
the unification of all hugo slavs
free from austria the event sparked a
series of escalations in europe
the july crisis which ultimately caused
world war one
a war that ended on armistice day
november 11 1918
pretty odd huh a
spooky coincidence if you will but look
odd things happen
all the time oddness is all around us
especially in the form of odd numbers
the grip they have on our reality is
revealed
when we release our grip
notice anything strange under the
influence of gravity
things move in an odd way
if something starts moving because of
gravity after
say one second it will have traveled
some distance
now interestingly during the next second
the distance it will travel will be
three times as far as it moved
during the first second during the third
second it will travel
five times as far then seven times
then nine times eleven thirteen fifteen
we used seconds but it doesn't matter
what time interval you use
you will always find this pattern the
odd number rule hiding
right there within the very phenomenon
that keeps us on earth
are the odd numbers more like
god numbers right is the odd number rule
the face of
the universe looking back at us well
here is something that galileo wrote
philosophy is written in this grand book
i mean the universe which stands
continuously open to our gaze
but it cannot be understood unless one
first learns to comprehend
the language in which it is written it
is written
in the language of mathematics and its
characters
are triangles circles and other
geometric figures
without which it is humanly impossible
to understand
a single word of it without these
one is wandering about in a dark
labyrinth
before this pattern in the grand book of
the universe was
read and appreciated people wondered
why things fell maybe stuff just
has a desire to be in its own proper
place right rocks with the earth fire
with the air
that makes sense right it was fun to
imagine causes
and write our own stories but underneath
our desire for
explanations a story was already being
told
one that is written in the language of
mathematics
measure and relation now many of these
stories are being told all around us all
the time one on top of each other
but if we can look past those
disturbances
each isolated event is narrating a quiet
simple story not of why the universe is
but of what the universe is
galileo recognized what this pattern
spelled
mathematically it spells hello
i am speeding up at a constant rate and
that was huge
all this time for millennia we had been
wondering
about the causes of gravity its cosmic
purpose
why it existed but now here was someone
saying
yeah yeah cool but like what does it do
it makes things fall great well what
does that mean what does it mean to fall
fall how now the human mind alone
couldn't answer that but the universe
was
telling us we just had to speak its
language
and read it this is i am gaining
velocity at a constant rate
spelled with odd numbers how
well what's an odd number the
concept of oddness comes from the
observation that sometimes when you have
a bunch of things everything you have
can
be paired up but sometimes
that can't happen now when it's possible
when you can pair everything up that you
have it is said that the number of
things you have
is even if you can't do that
then the number of things you have is
odd
now what this means is that the number
of objects
in an even group is equal to 2
times n where n is just the number of
whole pairs that you have so n is any
whole number
n could be for example 50 giving us the
even number of
100 which is also the number of legs
centipedes have or is it
centa 100 peed feet having 100 legs
is right there in the name but it's only
approximate
centipedes have been observed to have
anywhere from 30
to 345 legs now 100
falls pretty nicely in that range
but every pair of legs on a centipede is
attached
to a body segment which means that in
order to have 100 legs
a centipede would need to have 50 body
segments
but not a single species of centipede
has an even number of body segments
50 segments is nowhere to be found in
the library of centipede genomes
so while centipedes on average have a
number of legs
quite close to 100 they never
naturally have exactly 100
point is 2n is the mathematical way to
spell
even if i add just one more thing
the amount i have is no longer even it's
odd
if i add yet another thing i've added
another pair and has gone up by one and
the number is even again
this means that an even number plus just
one more
will always be odd now that we know how
to mathematically spell
odd and even we can move on
to moving if you and me
hugged well that would be wonderful we
would both get so much out of it but if
during the hug you suddenly ran away
from me
while yelling i'm leaving you at a
velocity of two meters per second
well i would be devastated but i would
know that deep down you still
cared for me because you told me your
velocity
and if i know your velocity i can know
just how far away you are from me
at all times all i have to do is take
your velocity and multiply it by the
number of seconds that have elapsed
since you left now take a look at what a
graph
of your velocity would look like here we
have
velocity in meters away from me per
second and we have
time in seconds since the hug ended now
if your velocity is two meters per
second and that persists
then here's a graph of your velocity but
look at this
after a number of seconds have elapsed
like after one second
the distance you are away is just the
rate times the time elapsed two times
one well that also happens to be the
area of the rectangle bounded by
a line coming up from the time your
velocity graph and our
axes well that's pretty convenient after
two seconds
you are two times two four meters away
from me
which is also the area of this shape
we've created
after three seconds you are three times
two one two three four five
six meters away it's always the area
well that's pretty convenient
but let's change up the story what if we
hugged
and it was great i mean just
almost not even a hug like something new
is being invented here
but then during that you suddenly leave
you run away from me
and while you run you yell i am leaving
you at an ever-changing velocity
well i would say you know what that is a
lot less helpful
now let's say that this changing
velocity you have that i don't know
happens to be an acceleration of two
meters per second per second what does
that mean well that means that your
velocity
is getting bigger by two meters per
second for
every second that you run it would look
like this on a graph
you begin hugging me with no velocity
and then one second later your velocity
is
two meters per second larger so two
larger than zero is two
that's your velocity after one second
after two seconds your velocity is two
larger still
so four and then six
your velocity graph would look something
like this
but now here's a question if you're
moving like this
is the distance you are away from me at
any given time
still just the area of the shape
bounded it's harder to see that because
you don't maintain
any single velocity for any amount of
time your velocity is always changing so
we don't have nice
rectangles but we can see that it is
true
by putting ourselves in my shoes
abandoned alone i don't even know
your emotion i don't even know how
you're accelerating
it's very scary but i can decide to take
matters into my own hands
and measure your velocity as often as i
like
let's say that i measure it just once i
measure it after
let's say two seconds all right
wonderful now the question i want to
answer
is how far away you are after
three seconds all right so i have this
measurement i know that you were
traveling
at four meters per second well
i mean look if you're going four meters
per second
for one second then that's a
rectangle like this and it's got an area
of four um but you're not four meters
away are you you're a lot
further than that because you weren't
traveling four meters per second for
this entire second you were at all times
actually traveling
a bit faster and i'm totally forgetting
all the distance you covered before my
measurement which is not
zero okay so clearly i need to measure
your velocity more frequently
so let's say that i measure your
velocity twice during the three seconds
i'm curious about let's say i measure it
after one second and then after two
seconds
well now i can imagine rectangles here
this one is two by one so it has an area
of two
this one is four by one so it has an
area of four
two plus four is six but you're a lot
more than six meters away as well
because you weren't traveling two meters
per second this entire time you were
actually speeding up covering more and
more distance
i'm totally forgetting all the distance
you covered over here basically
this method will always leave me short
but
the more frequently i check your
velocity the better things get
take a look at this oh yeah
oh wow as you can see the more
frequently i check your velocity the
closer my calculation gets to being
based off of what you really did your
actual motion
but also the more frequently i check
your velocity
the closer the combined area of all of
my rectangles gets to simply being equal
to the actual
area bounded by your velocity curve
which means
that the area under your velocity curve
even when your curve is like this
is still totally the distance you are
away from me
now let's take this knowledge and apply
it to the odd number rule
before people knew how things fell there
were some pretty good guesses
for example if the reason things fall is
that
they have within them a desire to be in
their own proper place
uh in this example the table well then
maybe
the closer this object gets to the table
the more excited it is to be there and
the faster it goes
in which case its velocity would change
over time like this
getting steeper and steeper and steeper
but galileo didn't think that
he believed that when objects fell their
velocities
increased at a constant rate so graphed
like this
their velocity would just follow a
straight line
let's draw a straight line beautiful
now let's divide this graph up into
strips of equal
time perfect all right now as we know
the areas of the shapes we have bounded
here
are the distances traveled during their
respective
time intervals so what's the area
of our first shape here a little
triangle well we don't know what it is
we don't have any
um actual markings here on our axes but
that's fine it doesn't really matter
we'll just call this one so in the first
second or the first time interval our
object traveled a distance
of one unit of space
perfect now how far did our object
travel during the second
time interval well that distance will be
equal to that area well what is this
area
well one thing we can do to make this
easier is to divide the shape
like this now we have two shapes a
triangle and a rectangle
this triangle has the exact same area
as our initial triangle that's because
they are congruent triangles
they both have the same base length and
because this velocity
line has a constant slope it rises the
same amount
per time elapsed all the time so
their heights are the same and they're
both right triangles their areas are the
same
so the area of this space is
the area of that triangle plus the area
of this rectangle what is the area of
this rectangle well
one thing we can do is divide the
rectangle in half
with a diagonal like this and look what
we've created
this triangle has the exact same area as
our initial triangle it has the same
height
it has the same base they're both right
angles and look
the same goes for this one it's a right
triangle its base is the same as this
space its height is the same as this
one's height
gosh this is just the area of the
initial triangle but
twice so we have two of them and we have
two of them
one time okay perfect now let's move on
to finding the area of that shape once
again i can divide
this shape like that
and now i have a triangle which as we
know has the same area
as our initial triangle right here so we
have
that area one and then we also have
look at that two rectangles which as we
know we can divide in half like this
giving us now four triangles equal
in area to the initial one so what we've
done is we've taken the initial
area and we have doubled it uh well once
and then twice so two times
now as we continue doing this we find
that we're always
adding one more of our original areas
and then we're always
doubling that original area one more
time here we've doubled it one two
three times doubled three times we'll
look at this pattern
right here we can think of one as being
equal to two times
zero plus one can't we well these
numbers are whole numbers and they're
just going up by one
zero one two three this is all
of the general form two n plus 1.
that is how you mathematically spell odd
so the odd number rule is not some kind
of magical coincidence
it's just what happens when an object's
velocity
increases at a constant rate the answer
was right there in front of us all along
written
in the mathematical language of the
universe
the universe also contains colorado
one of its best rectangles
or is it let's find out after a quick
word from our sponsor
us hi i'm michael stevens
are you a person well then get out of
here
go poop or something i only want to talk
to your brain
okay so brains here's my message to you
treat yourself touch more than just my
voice
become a supporter of the vsauce
curiosity box
the subscription for thinkers it comes
to your door every three months full of
stuff that we have made
and things that we love i'm talking
books shirts viral physics toys
puzzles projects you name it its mission
is to be good
for brains so we give a portion of all
proceeds from it directly to alzheimer's
research
and it makes our new inquisitive
fellowship
possible a program that literally just
gives money
and equipment and assistance to
educational youtubers
so they can worry less about
monetization and the algorithm
and more about just making the kind of
content they want to make
and that this world needs this year's
inaugural fellows are fantastic
12 tone jordan herod up and adam and
jabril you should definitely subscribe
to them
continue feeding yourself right join
the curiosity box today
welcome back now colorado looks like a
rectangle
a shape with four sides that all meet at
the same angle
but colorado doesn't have four sides
it has 697 making it
not a rectangle but instead a hexa hecta
india contact heptagon
and this was all by mistake the united
states congress initially defined
colorado as a geospherical rectangle
the space bounded by two lines of
latitude and two lines
of longitude in the 19th century
surveyors set out to demarcate its shape
to actually mark it on the ground
and they did a phenomenal job with the
tools that they had
but mistakes were made some were large
enough that you can spot them on many
common maps of the state
in 1925 the us supreme court ruled that
the borders
as surveyed were the correct ones and
would legally stand as the official
recognized edges of the state not the
originally intended theoretically pure
geospherical rectangle thus
ending the shaping of colorado that
began with lines drawn by the compromise
of 1850 18
we have arrived article 18
section 5 paragraph 0 of the washington
interscholastic activities association
1996-97 constitution the set of rules
airbud would have been subject to at the
time and place of the movie
states that in order to participate in
an interscholastic athletic activity
like basketball a student must be a
quote
regular member of the school defined as
someone enrolled half
time or more the section does refer
to rcw 28a 225010 a list of approved
exceptions
but not one of these was considered in
the case of airbud
had they been it would have been
discovered quite quickly
that airbud the dog qualified under
absolutely
none of them there is no rule that
specifically states
a dog cannot play basketball but there
are and were rules that said that this
dog
airbud should not have been allowed to
play
basketball and as always thanks for
[Music]
watching